nueva york- una megalópolis de 8
millones y medio de habitantes hoy
amenazada por la subida de las aguas con
su geografía tan particular la gran
manzana está rodeada por el océano
atlántico y los ríos este y edson con
las precipitaciones que se multiplican
estos últimos años el riesgo de
inundación es importante el huracán
sandy en el 2012 pero también ida y ndri
este verano han destruido barrios
enteros de manhatan y concientizarán a
la gente
sandy fue el primer evento catastrófico
que en gran parte volcó nuestra atención
hacia el cambio climático y hoy pueden
ver el resultado de esta preocupación
que son todos estos proyectos muy muy
importantes para proteger a los
neoyorquinos
uno de estos proyectos prevé la
elevación de los espacios verdes sobre
cuatro de los 819 kilómetros del litoral
de la ciudad la construcción de muros
que eviten las inundaciones y adaptables
según la fuerza de las tormentas que
hemos instalado pilotes como cimentación
profunda y luego instalado las barras
metálicas que formarán un muro de
separación subterráneo para protegernos
de las inundaciones formaremos también
la fundación que pueden ver y como veis
en la última sección estamos vertiendo
hormigón lo que nos dará un muro similar
al que veis detrás de mí para la
construcción de las obras debería
culminar en 2026 mientras que las
últimas proyecciones de los expertos
climáticos estiman que el nivel del agua
subirá de 20 a 75 centímetros de aquí a